hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
software tutorial and in this one i'll
be showing you a frequently asked
question you wouldn't believe how many
people have asked me this since the new
itunes 9 came out and that is how to
create an account with the new itunes 9
without using a credit card so let's
just go right into this guys
so like i mentioned earlier itunes 9
came out not too long ago uh fairly
recently and people have been asking me
since then how do i create an itunes 9
account uh without using a credit card
in order to download a few free
applications use a free a few free
things and uh you know just get to use
itunes nine in a better way so i'm i'm
gonna show you guys how to do this
really quickly all you have to do is
have the newest version of itunes and
that will be in a link in the
description at apple's website so in
order to create your account just go to
the store tab under here and click
itunes store and this will bring up the
new itunes store now it has changed a
little bit the applications won't be on
the right hand side so you can't get
apps from the home page anymore you have
to be at the top and hit the app store
drop down and pick any sort of
application i'm just going to hit the
app store button in general because it
doesn't really matter to me now on the
right hand side you'll see your charts
for top paid apps and top free
applications this is where you want to
be so you go ahead and select any free
application and click the free button
next to it and you'll be prompted to
either sign in or create a new account
obviously we want to create a new
account so once we hit that button we
hit continue and this is the the main
step you might or might not have seen
before uh this is the same as the last
version of itunes nine so once we
continue we want to accept the terms and
the terms and conditions of itunes
obviously uh first we're going to enter
our email address i'm going to
blur this out
next we enter your password and re-enter
it to confirm it
and we're going to answer
enter a question
and your answer to the question then go
ahead and enter your birthday i don't
really mind people seeing my birthday
like if you have the same birthday as me
just let me know and uh would you like
to receive the following email just
whatever you want check that will not
affect this process hit continue down at
the bottom right oh please enter at
least six letters or numbers for your
question so that's something you have to
make sure you input so
let's change this a little bit
and hit continue once you've made sure
all the steps are valid now this is the
step that only shows up when you try to
download a free application you can
choose your credit card obviously visa
mastercard etc all the way on the right
hand side here you can select none and
the field box will actually refresh so
you don't have to enter credit card
information i think this is a really
nice feature i don't know why you have
to go around it around itunes to get to
this feature but it's really nice that
they do include it so go ahead and enter
your address and all that information
and hit continue i'll be back after i've
done that
all right i've inputted all the
information and now we're just going to
hit the continue button again on the
bottom right hand side and it says
verify your account and an email has
been sent to the address that you
inputted in the field and you'll go
ahead and click a link in that email to
verify your account and complete your
setup so just go ahead and hit done
and go ahead and open up your email
client whatever that might be and make
sure you uh verify using the email that
apple sent you and you officially have
uh created your itunes account so i'm
going to go back after i've verified my
email and demonstrate that this actually
works by signing in
so once you open your email client
whatever that might be i happen to use
mozilla thunderbird and opentp an open
source piece of freeware you can find
the link to in the description
either way once you've clicked the link
that apple sends you in your email you
can go ahead and open itunes again and
it'll say sign in to complete account
creation so just use the account
information you just used to sign up so
i'm going to enter that
and the password you just entered as
well
i'm just going to type that again
because i want to make sure and go ahead
and hit sign in to complete everything
and i'm pretty sure this is the last
step yes so on the right hand side
you'll see your account information
you'll see that you are signed in and
your itunes store account has been
successfully created so you can now shop
and purchase
things you don't have to actually
purchase anything if you do purchase
you'll need to enter credit card info
but if you want to download anything for
free let's say podcasts or free
applications you don't need any credit
card information and you're pretty much
good to go so thank you for watching
this hd tutorial from mkbhd i hope this
was helpful
to all you people who asked me how to
create an account without any credit
card information and uh good luck
downloading all your free applications
and good luck with all that so anyway i
hope this tutorial was helpful and thank
you for watching and thank you for
subscribing for those of you who have
done so so far and if this did help you
out leave a comment just so i know that
it's worked or i'll take it down if it
didn't actually work so again thank you
for watching and i'll talk to you guys
in the next video peace